وخططه العسكريه اصبحت حديث العالم
والمعلومات السريه في ادراج وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه المغلقه تم تسريبها الى العلن
فما هي اهم هذه التسريبات صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز قالت ان المعلومات الوارده في هذه
الوثائق عمرها خمسه اسابيع على الاقل
وكانت اغلبها تتناول الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وتجسسات امريكا على حلفائها
ايضا احدى الوثائق فصل جداول تدريب اثني
عشر لواء قتاليا اوكرانيا يتم تدريبه من
قبل امريكا والناتو فيما تناولت وثائق
اخرى حجم الخسائر البشريه للجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني
التسريبات كشفت ايضا معلومات حول اسرائيل
بشان استعداداتها لارسال اسلحه قتاليه الى
اوكرانيا وان قاده كبارا في المساده او
للاحتجاج على الاصلاحات القضائيه وفيما لا
تزال هذه الوثائق تثير جدلا واسعا تحركت
وزاره العد الامريكيه وفتحت تحقيقا لكشف
ملابسات تسريبها